all right Mike tree trunks buttons seem
to really work they're raising tree
trunks awareness because G is back and
it's wonderful oh okay so this is
crystals head power we have joy in this
one cuz she is also a huge tree trunk
span yes good good to have her back and
yes until she eats another crystal Apple
blows over something but yeah so this is
a episode where these couch I remember
how started out remember oh yeah there's
a crystal yeah they get this pink
crystal that has like her lipstick mark
on there and turns out that's where she
went when she ate the Apple and then
blew up there and so they what quit all
crystal men I remember that cuz it sound
a lot like crystal meth
I was one 8010 show I don't think it was
but so these crystal men come out say
they're good and take Finn and go back
in and I love the voices for these guys
they're just there at your mum you lava
henchman from adventure or no the
Monarchs Hegeman Oh Venture Brothers
yeah yeah I almost said adventure
brother seeing the two shows um that'd
be an interesting myth yeah I know
quitting on the monarch somebody do the
crossover got the glitz together like
yeah like Jake could be like going after
that Cartoon Network right this
crossover has to happen okay
they got make that happen okay so um
yeah so so the gun says were on the
turning Finn into a crystal and Jake
decides he doesn't want to be violent
anymore cuz he's just thinks back to his
childhood and like his supposedly
abusive but not abusive but what's him
to be abusive but they finds out to bad
people so it's okay and he fights back
and Finn's turn into a crystal but then
turns out that tree trunks was in this
world and turned into their crystal
Queen and they all just loved her for
whatever reason and if she just destroys
them I feel kind of bad for them
actually it's like after you left
no it's funny but at the same time it's
like they just come in for whatever
reason
just totally in love with her and then
she's just like and blows them up
absolutely yeah yes yes God and they get
the whatever they crystal Apple out of
her and then she turns back to her you
know cute ad self and they go home and
and make an apple pie and there's a
great apple pie I loved it I buy at
first I was really afraid because I
thought they were gonna like just make
her a villain and keeper a villain I'm
like no no don't do the tree trunks but
where'd they get the a power she's fine
uh like I said the crystal men I think
are really funny in this and the way
they slow down the voices and make him
talk it just it just really remind me of
Venture Brothers tonight I had no
problem with that because I love the
henchmen Venture Brothers and yeah I
thought was just really fun really cool
and I like the colors - I like sir the
particularly with the crystal men like
just the like the line work around it's
not just black lines or sort of like
their colors that complement each other
and stuff so yeah I loved it how about
you Jerry I loved it I absolutely loved
it I loved the whole Jake thing what got
me a lot was this I'm going to do like
my really soft touch god stop it
he's trying desperately and it's it's
it's this funny bizarre thing cuz it's
like he goes back well it starts because
he he ends up accidentally sitting on
Finn when they were playing remember
they were playing yeah and then he felt
bad because phen kind of got hurt but
not really Finn did not cry for 30
minutes you know and and then he
remembered that he hurt his brother
somehow they were boxing and he heard
his brother and his dad comes in you
will hurt everybody just do it go do
hurt everybody so it's it's kind of like
that kid teenager II know fuck you did
I'm gonna do what you want me to do I'm
not gonna be who you say I'm gonna be
well especially because under that
understand you see is like very violent
very never that great sigh oh no hurt
bad people okay well when the best part
I think of that was for me was when the
dad right at the end did that it was
like well you never let me finish dad
meant to say you're gonna hurt all the
bad people but he didn't hear that part
he just you never let me finish
you're gonna hurt all the bad people oh
okay what kids do never let their
parents finish a system but they never
do and well and what I like you too is
that like apparently if well probably
find out that he has a brother that's
still alive which is interested just
like oh like how come he never goes
visitors he is ever anything but
apparently oh he said like you know when
he he's like how are you dead - it's
like no no I'm just dreaming - oh it's
oh I guess dreams sort of cross jury I
don't know but yeah I'm wondering if he
shows up in anything else
but yeah how about you Jason I'm not a
fan of tree trunks oh you lied no
actually I'm really not really a frickin
wall tree junkie not long tree trunks
she's so sexy with her junk in the trunk
Barriss what you also have to understand
is we've learned that someone has a
prehensile penis so maybe that's why you
likes the whole trunk aspect and all
that stuff just think of the
possibilities that could be done with it
man but no I've never been a huge fan of
tree trunks she's fine but she reminds
me of that annoying old relative that
consistently just talks and does what
they want she's so nice though to makes
apple pie and then I allowed to get away
with it because they're old and they say
things so nicely she's like the dementia
grandma but oh my girl's grandmother
you're so crazy but we love you oh well
let him get away because of their nuts
and you talk no huge crush on Finn first
of all which is really unhealthy yeah
it's like this is like your crush on
yeah but she's of age I'm assuming the
bestiality aspect doesn't enter into it
okay
oh so you're more we're just age yeah
yeah that's where it's wrong but if an
animal bet some especially if it's a
animal consent and she can say yes or no
yeah dear PETA I'm that part of this
conversation please don't egg my house
oh wait they wouldn't egg it because
I'll be wasting eggs in that be exactly
oh oh no no I like the episode as a fun
episode the crystal guards were my
favorite just the way that the one
specifically kept responding to Jake and
everything just go away you're gonna
hurt yourself
like he didn't care and then the two in
the background are always on their
phones doing oh sorry yeah you have to
keep reminding it like why they even
kidnap them to begin with
are you evil uh no we're good
oh okay that's me grab them i I was just
the the actor who plays Finn even now
cuz I don't the show is still going is
he still playing Finn or did they get
another actress why does he know what
still him does because in this episode
it sounds like his voice is starting to
change a little bit does it growing up
no I know I'm saying does it change all
the way through like that's because the
Earth's seasons gotta be few years later
I mean does it it don't doesn't get a
lower voice or is it still no keep
watching actually no i yeah Jory's right
no one you're right I'm not here for fun
guy you do a good job good great mission
accomplished
anything else
I don't like I like her elegance - yeah
Deus be one thing else come on let's get
out of here come on no it's gonna do an
odd zone got these right here yeah
so how you doing yeah yeah good let me
never get rid of her know how much we
hate her
okay so I really hate tree trunks I
think she's the worst character is he
just like how I'm sexy is that like that
especially when she does this doesn't
work anymore cuz that was not her plus
you know it's let Morley look there it
don't do that again
why not cuz it's not her